Mi az, ami bennük emberi, és az AI sosem
fog tudni lecserélni? Ez egy fontos
kérdés. Ugyanis amikor a chat GPT 3.5-ös
megjelent, akkor az emberek elkezdtek
vele csevegni, és egy idő után
megnyugodtak, hogy hát ez még azért nem
az a szint, ami ami átvenni a munkámat.
Aztán megjelent a 4ó. És akkor
gondolkoztak az emberek, és azt mondták,
hogy hát de a matekben nagyon rossz. És
megjelent az O1-es változata, majd az
O3-as változata, ami kvantummechanikai
képeteket old már meg. És akkor
gondolkoztunk azon, hogy rendben, az
írás tekintetében tényleg veri az ember,
de mi a helyzet a a hang beli
interakcióba? Ott még egy elég
robotikus, még elég unalmas a a chat
GPT. És akkor megjelent februárban a
sezam.com, majd nézzetek utána egy
hihetetlenül realisztikus hang. Olyan,
mint a P, a 2013-as film. Egyszerűen
megdöbbentű. És akkor azt mondjuk, hogy
jó, de nincs keze, nincs lába, nincs
teste, és látjuk ezeket a humanoid
robotokat, ahogy fejlődnek. Azt hiszem,
hogy elérkezett az idő, hogy mélyen
végiggondoljuk, hogy mitől ember az
ember, és mi az, ami soha nem fog
lecserélni bennünk az AI.